Speaker 1: Let's try our friend Eric from
Cancun. Eric, how are things in beautiful,
sunny, humid Cancun, Mexico, today?
Speaker 2: And. Right now we have a storm. And
as you can see, it's a Big East that I want to
do an encore about. Something we say already said
our beautiful twin would be. I would be
in. When I said about the toxic fandoms,
about icons, I sent them in and made a
strong stand to point out how toxic venom is.
Well, then, let's also say that as time said, the
artists are to blame for the when bad people do
bad stuff and they blame the artists because
thinking that they're being manipulated for that
and seeing them, they're blaming video games for
the shoot that happened right now. And also that
it would be unfair to blame J.D. Salinger
that they killed John Lennon. Hmm.
Speaker 1: Eric, do you think that the Johnny Depp
Amber Heard trial is an example of toxic fandom?
Speaker 2: And if I would be, because usually
they blame men for the abuse of domestic
and in the house. But I believe that John is
innocent in this time. But this will be more like
when they were blaming Michael Jackson for being a
pedophile. But then the kids called him convinced
that it was his dad's idea to lie about it.
Speaker 1: Wow. I'm not super familiar with that
case. That's amazing. Eric, what else is on your
mind today? I know you always have a big agenda.
Speaker 2: But also when I mention about Occam's
Razor, then I told you that right wingers and
conspiracy theories want to be like James Bond,
but they can barely make it to Austin Powers. And
the problem would be that aside from wanting to be
a superspy. The thing is that they would believe
in those things because one of their biggest fears
is another is admitting that they were wrong.
But there would be times that I wish to be wrong
when I know something bad is going to happen.
Sometimes will be when I know that the news will
become than them. But with Brian King's landing.
Awesome. When I work with the staff, say Björk,
and also when SOCO will be Drake at that.
Right. Also, when when they are going to
die to save the multiverse from Thanos.
Speaker 1: Well, Eric, you've really said
it all. I only understand about 15% of it,
but it's such a pleasure to hear from
you, and I hope you're doing well.
Speaker 2: And when my. When there's
one. Okay. And. Soon there will be a
bargain. They say the politician would
be based their policies in cartoons.
And if you'll remember, Rand Paul costarred when
put himself as Satan Jaeger from Attack on Titan
and killed Joe Biden as the colossal Titan.
Speaker 1: I do remember that. Yeah. Paul
Gosar published this cartoon of him like appearing
to kill be killed by Biden and or AOC, I think.
Speaker 2: It's Yemen. There would be spoilers in
before an end becomes a title. And then he wants
to use his powers to kill the all the titles
to save humanity from being eaten by them. But
in the fourth season, he becomes a sociopath
because he blames the neighbor kingdom for
creating the Titans and he kills 80%
of the population. So maybe it will
feed to his in the party of being genocidal.
Speaker 1: Well, Eric, you've said it all. I
really appreciate your call. Okay.
Speaker 2: You'll be good. All
right. Say hi to your cousin for me.
Speaker 1: Oh, of course, Farren. Absolutely. I
will say hi to Farren. There is Eric from Cancun
with another powerful declaration of all kinds